foreign
[Music]
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
that I wish you go
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
I didn't want to make things perfect
we just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
foreign
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
tell me something
you can go anywhere
[Music]
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay and fight to
save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with
magnets
[Music]
this is my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
completely broke the universe
we've been waiting for you
created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
here
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
Miss Cara
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
foreign
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are
building This Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something a little piece of it he said
Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing some of my love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear
boom
built such a beautiful life filled with
love and family I never got that chance
you stole that from me
my few
my future my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
beat by piece
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
they've lost
he's trying to tear us apart
when it used to be about winning we
raised for respect
today I race to stop the blood back
[Music]
the problem with having such a big
family how do you choose the ones you
save
Let's Race
[Music]
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
recognizes game
all right
I'm coming for you son
that's right
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
and morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]
oh it was all a dream the name's Mirage
come on kill tap okay
relax a mirage remember
[Music]
ah
we're too high up we can't get down from
here
[Music]
you're almost here
thank you
[Music]
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place it's a shrine
guys
we've got to lure him in
we execute them
come on mother
it's for you
in theaters March 10th tickets on sale
now
my memory is a little fuzzy are you
still a Nazi
[Music]
Indiana Jones
I'm ready
here I come cause I'm ready
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
but he doesn't anymore
hey I'm just getting started little bro
I'm coming for everything
[Applause]
don't let him destroy everything you've
built
here I come
[Music]
65 exclusively in movie theaters March
10th oh we're the Mario Brothers in
plummets again we're not let the others
who get all the things
we're faster than the others you'll be
hooked on the brothers
thank you Super Mario Bros it seems like
the only thing you haven't drained is my
bank account
for Super Service call or text Super
Mario Bros Plumbing today at
92955 Mario or reach us on the world
wide web at smbplumbing.com
we're facing the greatest evil
the world has ever known
[Music]
how are we gonna pull this off
figure it out over a drink
Dungeons and Dragons
[Music]
you know when you get a Feeling
sometimes 20 years I've never had a
feeling like this you're gonna see
exactly what I see
greatness I need the greatest basketball
shoe that's ever been made what's the
plan we build a shoe line around just
him for a rookie who's never set foot on
an NBA court who's a player
Michael Jordan
get Michael Jordan I'm thinking of
reaching out to the parents you talk
directly to the family you're gonna lose
your job do you typically show up at
people's front doors unannounced I was
told not to call oh man here we go
every once in a while
someone comes along that's so
extraordinary that it forces change
because they are so very special a shoe
is just a shoe until my son steps into
it
there rated R exclusive exclusion
theaters April 5th
[Music]
foreign